hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
we're gonna watch this trailer for a
video game called Assassin's Creed Krieg
creet rogue the story trailer ah you
know there's a movie called assassins
that starred Antonio Banderas Anubis
booboo I am an assassin assassin to do I
have Antonio Banderas
I wish the games like that a little bit
I'll go but I wish Antonio Banderas was
the star of every game I have even rated
M for [ __ ] you
che was an assassin
man our daily hide you he was a friend a
brother for LMS only the first hour of
training a pity boy has so much
potential it's the little discipline
I've tried the Templar as far as Coast
but I fear the rest is up to you my
friend
oh wow
you made me sutra innocence and will no
let this happen again
brother he's coming to hunters all the
badass story and he was identity Khalid
estamos expect disappoint I don't plan
to sir like will kill every last man who
defends him if I burst
thank stealing from your brother
we don't have the right to decide that
they share the right we have the
responsibility
everyone use our worst enemy
someone must make events Assassin's
Creed rogue dude I can um a certain
black friends of mine I said I could
[ __ ] with that game what that means I
could like you know I could get down
with that game okay
like I can play that like dude I found
myself really wanting to be that guy
yeah like would you watch like a revenge
story and you like want revenge for that
character you're like yeah I feel you
getting revenge right now I feel your
revenge bro yeah that's a problem I was
like I want I want to be disc I feel
like like when I'm actually winning and
beating people up I'll be like yes
that's right getting my revenge like I'd
be so into it I got emotional problems I
need to work on personally before I can
film yeah you just need a plate of bacon
looks good out of all the assassin creed
trailers and the games that I've seen
this one for some reason looks a lot
more interesting
it'll feels more personal it feels more
personal like yeah you can just identify
with it much easier you know I don't
want to say that the other ones don't
have substance cuz that's not true at
all but like this one for some reason
just feels like there's a lot more
emotion in exactly something driving
things with Assassin's Creed it's like
you really focus on the puke bucket
scope of everything this one seems like
no this is a real personal tale about
someone you know like looking back on
the other trailers I feel like this is
the first trailer that really kind of
like showed like characters and not like
these are the dudes you need to kill
yeah here's you there's dead steadies -
true true that son mm-hmm
true dad turn a homie my black friends
use the n-word but I can't use that oh
just because I have black friends
doesn't mean I could use that word yeah
that's true apparently that's this is
unfair if you knew the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and Dan
he has gaming channel Oh Xbox Kinect you
can did you just air-quote my gaming
channel yeah
what the [ __ ] bro I honestly forgot the
use of air quotes on what they say it
implies that I have a gaming channel but
it's not really a gaming channel oh okay
I thought I was just quoting it to help
gaming that and not work then everybody
hates us I thought everyone hates it
it's because they it's smart because he
gets you immediately to say that so it's
a it's a psychological game Ryan right
my mag give me and my channel a
shout-out not the one they need the one
they deserve it's the one you deserve if
no one likes you
oh it's not the one that you need is
someone you deserve okay so when you
deserve okay well if everyone hates you
I'm going to assume there's a reason to
hate you so [ __ ] you that's it
[ __ ] [ __ ] when I say [ __ ] you say you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you wait you look like a
ten year old kid
Oh may the Lord bless you for the future
and any problems and obstacles that come
your way that God may guide you you
beautiful young soul you also may God
have mercy on our souls
yes it [ __ ] you to attend you yes agent
Washington cool like the name of that
your videos are hilarious
by the way gonna have a shout-out dude
agent Washington man if I just heard
that name I'd be like yeah yeah I want
to shout this guy out that just sounds
so cool he's got to be black what
Washington like Denzel sure Denzel
Washington could play agent Washington
in a movie hmm
yeah actually yeah I would believe an
actual hardcore drama if it was about
Denzel Washington playing himself and he
gets recruited by the CIA and becomes
agent Denzel Washington that is the
subscriber yeah you know what you and I
imagine we brought back George
Washington from the grave and I was a
soup super-secret agent for the CIA Oh
[ __ ] General Washington is badass
wooden teeth kicking down doors how he's
a
topping Russians yeah do WVU's immortal
yes that'd be like an awesome CBS drama
we should go for that or the best Adult
Swim cartoon and patent it no it's ours
it's our sister I'm writing the pilot
right now the gaming dragon hello hi
Ryan
I really enjoy your videos so much and I
gotta say that's what makes your videos
great is you and all your friends
because you are all the best
especially Alyssa she's so hot that is
all I have to say and may I please have
a shout-out that would be great thank
you - the gaming dragon PS you have a
nice-looking set of hair thanks man
you didn't say that last part no you
didn't gaming dragon you look young - so
we're not gonna [ __ ] this one up okay
you my friend
mmm-hmm if you believe in dragons
believe in puffing the magic dragon - it
helped these messed up Salisbury messed
up how what do you mean I'm trying to
help this guy off the future so what
would be the age that you would say
because it's their legal age on
marijuana now I think a 21 it's 18 yeah
okay I know this okay you believe in
love I don't know dude
Stan's losses should I've got much sleep
because play destiny I got a shirt but
gaming dragon you fly high you dragon
nice see I brought it back to that you
did fly high because it's inspirational
but you could also look at it as yep a
little bit of wheat middle data little
better way you just tea needs bead weave
in a baby big baby due to be people but